the patriots will be hanging their
banner not on the first thursday night
of the season but on the first sunday
night on nbc the pittsburgh steelers
come to town to take on the patriots the
past two years they had played week 15
in pittsburgh this year it's week one in
foxborough and the steelers now have
months where they can focus on this game
they can rally around we talked about
that earlier in the show the idea that
they're going to be salty they're going
to be upset the browns are the darlings
antonio brown and le'veon bell leaving
the steelers and all the comments about
ben roethlisberger i mean this gives
them a common goal a common vision a
common opponent that they can just focus
on until week one now the problem with
that is after you get through week one
you still have 15 games yeah but this is
something that can really carry them
through to the start of the season and
if they could start the season with a
win in new england what a different vibe
that would bring to what we think the
pittsburgh steelers could be this year
yeah i certainly give them confidence
with a team that's kind of you know i i
don't want to disrespect the pittsburgh
sheilders but new england's had their
way a little bit i remember big ben
saying it's kind of like the older
brother and we're the little brother and
we can't seem to pull out games last
year they finally did it uh but hey i
mean you can't uh overstate the
importance of of the early season and
the wins that you need to accumulate
there there's a reason i know we were
texting about this last night you know
to me when when i look at a schedule the
first thing i look at is you know the
team's first four five six games right
there's a reason we haven't seen many
teams get off to bad starts and win
super bowls or make deep playoff runs
it's just too hard in the nfl once you
get to get behind that eight ball early
on where all of a sudden you're one and
three or two and four and think oh okay
we're gonna go on some big time run here
i know it happens from time to time but
very rare and yeah when you look at a
team like pittsburgh to your point mike
new england week one and it's not like
life gets easier after that so it'd be
nice for them to get a win there because
they got the seattle seahawks coming
into town the week after that then
they'll have to fly to the west coast
and play the san francisco 49ers who are
going to be a team that's going to be
chomping at the bit because it's a big
year for jimmy garoppolo shanahan john
lynch so uh those early season wins are
big time and framing the rest of your
year whether you get in the playoffs the
seed the seeding you are in the playoffs
and that's usually the first thing i
look at
with each loss that window gets a little
more narrow whether you're trying to be
the one seed or the two seed or just to
get to the playoffs and if you come out
of september october at two and six
you're done three and five you're almost
done and so you want to win those games
early that's money in the bank that is
going to help you dramatically when it's
time to hit the playoff stretch you're
going to be a much different team
in december than you were in september
but those outcomes in september are
going to hover over you whether they're
good or whether they're bad rams browns
week three we played on the tv side
reaction in la as they were finding out
the schedule it was les sneed sean mcvay
erin donald and eric weddle and they
were very happy to learn that their trip
to cleveland comes in week three for a
team that struggles in cold weather you
want to be able to check those boxes hey
rams going to cleveland week three hell
of a lot better than week 13. you know
the vikings go to the packers and the
bears both in september that's got to
make a dome team very happy so the rams
instead because we saw what happened in
chicago last december for the rams this
this cleveland game could have been week
16 and they they avoided that and they
get it at a time when weather's not
going to be an issue and for the rams
that is an issue it is an issue and
those are the type of things that
players and coaches will look at you
know as crazy as it may seem i used to
look at it in tampa bay i'd be going
okay wait you know we're playing the
green bay packers are they coming you
know or do we have to go there in
december are we going to get there in
september the chicago bears teams like
that certainly and i look at the rams
schedule just specifically to what you
were saying they're very fortunate i
mean they're playing the afc north this
year the only time they have to go there
where it might be remotely cold is at
pittsburgh in week 10. other than that
they got the ravens at home so they're
gonna be happy about that they got the
bangles at home and and week eight so
for a team that is a little bit let's
see warm weather friendly uh those are
things that will jump out to them and
it's a nice home stretch for them where
they don't have to deal with those
elements late in the season
yeah they got enough issues other than
weather this year with jared goff who
knows which way he's going to go after
super bowl 53 todd gurley who knows
what's up with that knee to not have
those cold weather games to worry about
is a real bonus for the la rams as they
try to defend their nfc championship all
right when we return we'll look at the
best games of the year draft style right
here on pft live
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports